[Musique]
amazon est un acteur particulier on
parle souvent des gaffes à 1 au même
titre qu'on a un petit côté de la chine
les libertés x mais je crois que si on
revient on fait aujourd'hui le
e-commerce représente à peu près 10% des
ventes dans notre pays et dans ces 10 %
amazon c'est 20% donc on est sur 20% 2
10% alors certes on peut dire que dans %
c'est beaucoup c'est énorme et on est
loin d'un acteur qui vampirisent ray
toutes les ventes qui serait à 50 % 70 %
de part de marché donc je crois que en
effet on est plutôt sur une logique de
bouc émissaire car si on s'en réfère au
fait on a d'autres acteurs d'ailleurs
dans le e-commerce des acteurs français
on a des pépites
on peut parler de lebrou du bon coin sur
lequel les français vont beaucoup
évidemment aidé de beaucoup d'autres
donc je pense que réduire le débat à
amazon et peut-être au final un peu
simpliste que amazon doit respecter les
mêmes règles du jeu voyez un magasin
amazon e s'ouvrir avec une simple
autorisation préfectorale et à permis de
construire alors qu'un centre commercial
doit monter un gros dossier très
compliqué afin de s'ouvrir le centre
commercial et celui à une taxe sur les
mètres carrés au delà de 400 m² amazon
n'est pas alors ce genre d'inactivité
nous le combattons en tant
qu'organisation professionnelle et
notamment la mienne avec d'autres
acteurs le traitement des données de
tous les deux toutes les entreprises qui
ont contracté un péché eux le traité par
le groupe amazon ça ne me paraîtrait pas
convenable il faut que les choses
restent à leur place sinon comme je l ai
dit tout à l'heure en bas et monsieur
d'arona ne me contredira pas on va on
risquerait partir un déséquilibre et ce
n'est pas le but
[Musique]
bien évidemment on a la chance d'avoir
un secteur du e-commerce qui est très
dynamique d'ailleurs beaucoup aussi de
petits commerçants sont aussi sûrs sur
internet on l'a vu d'ailleurs que la
crise ait eu beaucoup d'évolutions sur
ce sur ce point là je crois que en effet
on peut se tourner vers vers d'autres
d'autres acteurs français il y en a il y
en a d'ailleurs beaucoup
amazon je rappelle d'ailleurs que plus
de 100000 p m commerce sur amazon et et
développent leurs produits donc on peut
aller sur amazon on peut aller sur
d'autres plateformes sans que les
français ont un sens patriotique c'est à
dire que on est souvent dans ces débats
sur de l'injonction il ne faut pas aller
sur amazon
il faut aller ailleurs je dirais les
français je pense consomme
localement on eu conscience que leurs
entreprises vont mal actuellement et
donc on faire travailler leurs artisans
du point loin des fantasmes de amazon
prend toute la place
je pense que les français sont assez
intelligente cas je les pense
responsable on sait que l'économie va
mal on sait que les entreprises vont mal
et donc prioriseront à la
responsabilisation de nos concitoyens
plutôt que les injonctions legrand
numérique et là ils fonctionnent bien
évidemment il a mieux fonctionné pendant
le coup vite parce que les boutiques
étaient fermées
mais quand même les boutiques ont
réouvert vous souvenez savent concourt à
ce que vous dites monsieur d'arona les
boutiques ont réouvert le 28 novembre et
vous avez vu cette faurie des
consommateurs qui se sont rués dans les
centres villes qui ont fait la queue
devant les magasins
parce que oui c'est vrai on a un sens un
certain sens patriotique patriotique sur
le plan commercial et nous souhaitons
faire travailler nos entreprises et je
parle
le coc u19 a déclenché un phénomène de
de révision 2
du fonctionnement du commerce on veut on
parle de relocalisation sur le
territoire français au niveau de
l'industrie agnès pannier une hache et
ses vertus tous les jours
art promouvoir la relocalisation des
acteurs industriels et elle a tout à
fait raison et le gouvernement va dans
le bon sens chaque semaine de retard ce
seront des difficultés en plus des
difficultés bien sûr de trésorerie de
fonds propres qui sont immenses pour nos
deux autres petits commerces et donc je
crois que la priorité c'est de sortir de
la crise sanitaire pour que la france
puisse redémarrer pour que nos
entreprises puissent d'or à redémarrer
et ensuite faire des choix forts pour
favoriser nos acteurs et je pense qu'on
peut tout à fait être dans la course
dans la compétition avec des acteurs
certes gros comme amazon mais la france
a toutes ses cartes à jouer dans cette
après que vides je reste conscient on
est en train de faire émerger
généraliser la pratique du numérique
auprès de toutes les villes auprès de
tous les commerçants c'est quelque chose
de fabuleux
on avait pris du retard les commerçants
physique notamment indépendant on avait
pris beaucoup de retard
on était pas on n'était pas réaliste et
là quand on a vu que le numérique le
grand rue méric pouvait absorber une
telle part de marché
on s'est réveillé et là maintenant on va
s'organiser pas forcément sous l'égide
d'amazon parce que amazon quand même
pour une entreprise ça coûte des
commissions de 15 à 20%
ce n'est pas forcément la solution rêvée
pour toutes les entreprises
je sais que les entreprises am
s'abonnent quelquefois amazon donc je
reste confiant et on va retrouver le
chemin de la sortie de crise et le
chemin du retour avec